nein auch schaut dann kannst du wieder
ärger soll wieder in dein haus bonn
das ist echter schönstes hier gesehen
habe dann haus von den wir aus
jetzt sind wir in einer neuen folge oder
hp neue themenvorschlag was haltet ihr
von stars die durch youtube berühmt
geworden sind nicht nur selbst sag mal
es gibt auch von unseren bestimmten
justin biebers ein gutes beispiel
es gibt doch so einen bestimmten namen
ich ach so ich dachte jetzt eher so an
uns jetzt zum beispiel die jetzt so ein
bisschen berühmter seien echte stars
also er hat da kann jetzt das lasse
lieber so wirklich das richtige beispiel
die erst zeitlich möglich ist wenn durch
youtube sind durch seine lieder auf
youtube sind die ganzen kämpfe ich bin
jetzt übrigens bei dir sind ja die
plattenfirmen darauf aufmerksam waren
bzw konnte sich dann entscheiden
zwischen usher und timberlake glaube ich
bin gesund also da sieht man schon was
das für ein fluss mittlerweile hat aber
ich sage dass das durch youtube wirklich
mittlerweile so die chance gegeben wird
oder sich das schön leuchtet das auch im
dunkeln dann müsste eigentlich weil es
ist sehr geil habe ich einpacken mit
eingebauten eigentlich müsste das ich
sehr schön ausverkauft das muss ich
sagen richtige landschaft wenn ich dir
dann in manchen tieren eine druckplatte
keinen grund das zehnte habe ich immer
meinen hintern treten
ich hab mit blinder fleisch im iran
getan weil damit geiles steg an der
reihe haftet ja keine ahnung was genau
die kommt darauf an was haltet ihr von
stars durch youtube berühmt geworden
sind
ja ok
ja ich meine was soll man davon halten
was hält man allgemein von stars ich
finds auch ganz gut also dass youtube
vor allem es war jetzt auch auf youtube
bezogen oder so ein paar stars und ihren
promi faktor muss man sich jetzt
streiten wie zb moneyball sollte auf gar
keinen fall so berühmt sein oder
haftbefehl weil das was die machen ist
sowas von unnötig oder julians blockt
aber was durch youtube mittlerweile
möglich ist es zum beispiel sieht man
auch einmal die band mittlerweile im
vertrag von sony music entertainment wo
ich nicht weiß warum er den oder wieder
den bekommen hat weil man weiß dass man
damit irgendwie geld verdienen können
der einzige grund
wir machen das ja nicht weil sie die
musik unbedingt gut finden sondern ja
warum daran damit geld zu verdienen dann
muss ja die musik in seiner mittlerweile
mischen die leute genau zu sagen kaufen
um so zu sagen hey komm ich leiste das
ist warum kauft man sich das dann das um
sich an stellen sich dabei zu lachen
warum schaut man sich schlecht
unterhaltung an wie schlechtes
fernsehprogrammen wie mitten im leben
tue ich nicht
aber machen viele mussten nicht nur von
dir ausgehen darf ich den du von mir aus
nur gibt auch keine andere menschen nein
die anderen sind alle nur projektionen
meines gehirns wenn es unser bewusstsein
so wie in einem traum
wie macht man diese bilder hängen kann
einfach keiner ab weil die projektion
merken dass sich das herausgefunden
hallo ich bin schon im bett
ich bin oft das motto der ließ das mal
vor dem gebannten modena hier am start
tübke panda panda war ja
den er manchmal firma team mit der voll
geil du bist du bist mal geblockt
in ställen zehner kann das dena die gema
nicht
ich wechsele ich den auch schon mit der
gema die gema darf es da nicht blocken
wenn die hier einfach so wieder sehen
oder wenn die äpfel von der tochter ein
geistiges eigentum also nicht der von
der immer aber ich geh mal vertritt die
interessen lehrer von den hinter den
musikern komponisten vor allem also wenn
justin bieber baby nicht geschrieben hat
sondern der grünen komponist und von der
plattenfirma dann vor allem dieser
komponist wir machen uns ja nur drüber
lustig geben das ja lustig wieder und
war mir keine kompetenz weg genau mit
diesem song wenn du kommst doch seine
ist ein video monetarisiert ist dann
sind es ganz klar kommerzielle zwecke
aber ja ich meine aber nicht anhand des
videos das gameplay das wird die arbeit
an der weg für den richtigen seien
einfach nicht
doch es geht ja nicht unbedingt vor
gericht denen einfach sofort recht
einfach gleich keine keinen links hier
gegen die mir kein leder die tür
ja diese tötest du dir denn welt sind
sie alle tot
alle bis auf ein paar weiße ich
verbrauche ein komplettes weizen dafür
dass ich eine farm aufbauen und den er
tritt das ganze mit seinen dreckigen
fließen
ich habe später zwar ganz viele kleine
baby für seine kühe gemacht mit
schuhgröße 52
ich glaube nicht minecraft paket sieht
aber schön aus ich wusste gar nicht so
toll bauen kann das gefährt abgekupfert
alles richtig machen das wie baut man
die eigentlich aus sechs sowie zäune nur
aus einem nur mit kann also wie die
zäune alt aber groß du im vergleich zu
minecraft pakets hause ist deine haut
nicht mehr komplett anderen ist er nicht
weiß was er die ganze zeit gemacht hat
gestern gestorben
das stimmt wohl das discount dabei sich
an bei einbauen
deswegen von unten aussieht wenn ich im
flachteil nach scheiße das ist ja dena
hier im staat
dafür schluckt aussehen doch worum ich
mir sorgen machen wie das aussieht wo
ich gerade bin
hinter dir das hier ist er abgebaut
jetzt wegen gesetz der ganze kommission
offengelegt
das zieht aber noch los geht aber noch
ich brauche noch ein paar tröpfchen uns
kommen welche nicht fertig eine
jakobsson abbauen
hier für mich etwas abbauen
vielleicht nehmen sie noch nicht wieder
in folge sechs minuten
es geht nicht nur ich weiß nichts das
geht nicht
was an mein mann ein neues thema wiwo.de
ich bin gleich endlich fertig mit der
farben
nein auch schade dass wir wieder
becker soll wieder in dein haus bauen
das ist echter schönes hier gesehen habe
mein haus denn das haus aber so eine
fragmentierte einfach jedesmal die zu
bauen ist wirklich so es rentiert sich
jetzt dass das geil das heißt es ist
geil
dann hätte er gesagt hat da es aber
nicht ihn doch das galt mir nein bin ich
da hinein für kinder
ich sage ja sage ich auch so geht es
nicht das kann ich mit meinem gewissen
nicht vereinbaren jetzt hier
gleich wieder an
muss mein vater
soll ich jetzt endlich wollen bauern
mutter schon total trocken einmal in die
kommentare für konkrete dem ich nutze
aggro berlin
deine fresse so hätte eine triste berlin
berlin nicht von akku oder nicht er halt
deine fresse ist doch von aggro berlin
dachte immer oder ziehen die das so groß
auf kennen das nur von deren
youtube-channel abo tv aggro tv startet
die am dass der von uns vor
aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht diesen bis
jimi blue ochsenknecht als auch schon
mal gemacht hat aber auch auf aggro
berlin channel da so wollte ich jetzt
machen eigentlich so türen machen für
diese holzzäune stein zu einer ich
glaube nicht dann bräuchte ja auch stein
sticks oder so die gibt es noch nicht
vielleicht den 1.7 oder 81 20 oder 25
jahren 350 zu leicht das sogar richtig
dann nochmals den letztens gesehen den
smiley ach so das war überhaupt der drei
smiley bedeutung also equals free alles
schreiben den aber ich verstehe er soll
so große augen lachen also richtig
sicher ich finde den abriss ich denke
schon geäußert haben und so an die das
ist essen
doppelpunkt es ja so eine schnute die
man oder gute das ist sozusagen ins
gesicht da gab es ja auch querelen hier
ohne textilien dahin damit dass die
apostel meint dass da kein tt darunter
ist dann ist gut hat meine ich den
ausgaben waren nicht so sinnlos zerstört
ich hab schon gedacht in die lava
darüber zu schützen aber das kriegen wir
schon aus komplett aus
das ist es dann auch bis in scheiße
du denkst auch nur an zerstören wird
über dem haus weiter baut du ich brauch
relativ armen events groß aber du bist
ja alle sagen immer älter muss man ein
haus weiter bauen doch immer um gefahren
war möchte ich es zu ende brachten
baustellen ist sein haus nicht fangen
will es auch nicht mehr wert als ein
quad auf dem feld wir haben nicht mein
feld doch mit karohemd ewig greifen
sondern kartoffel den brauchst du
eigentlich obwohl eine achse alles mit
der hand ab ich bin hart ja ich bin hart
ja ich bin hat er teils stein
ich bin ja wirklich geil aus das haus
ich ne moment nicht dein haus jetzt
selbst so stinkt nicht findet ich finds
doof ich bin nicht fertig da kann ich
dir einfach lösen
er befahl wenn du raus ich liebe diesen
zweiten geworden lalalalala ich färbe
ich hier immer